bonjour pascal de lima merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france nouvelle
dégringolade des marchés financiers ce
matin de la bourse de paris donc en
particulier qui a déjà souffert il ya
une dizaine de jours faut-il s'alarmer
beaucoup de valeur boursière on l'a dit
françaises sont à la baisse 1 oui il
faut s'alarmer
bien sûr sur la question de la gestion
des portefeuilles notamment au niveau
des banques et aussi sur la question des
rendements à venir pour beaucoup de
français c'est sûr que tout cela n'est
pas de bon augure par rapport à la
gestion purement financière et au
rendement d'un certain nombre de
produits financiers
maintenant ce qui arrive est quand même
très normal d'une certaine façon puisque
il y à un confinement à près d'un
milliard d'individus et donc si vous
enlevez le moteur d'une voiture la
voiture fonctionne plus donc je dirais
qu'il y à une récession qui impacte
aussi beaucoup les marchés financiers
mais c'est une récession particulière
puisqu'il est lié à un confinement
impose imposée s'ils voulaient donc un
ralentissement de l'économie mais tout à
fait imposer sous forme d'un diktat donc
c'est pas on n'est pas dans une crise de
la régulation du capitalisme quoi on est
vraiment dans une situation extrêmement
particulière pas de récession est ce que
c'est pire selon vous que les crashs
boursiers de 29 et de 73 pire que 2008
ans et washington parle d'un plan de
relance domestique un de 4000 milliards
de dollars notamment l'allemagne suspens
elle ces restrictions constitutionnel
sur la dette
oui les a vus mais a perdu 4% en 2007
2008 la france 3 % de pib là on va être
probablement aux alentours de chiffres
très très très similaires voire plus
mais je le précise qu' il n'y a rien de
très surprenant lorsque l'économie est
paralysée et lorsqu'on impose un
confinement donc je dirais que à mon
avis contrairement à ce que peuvent dire
certains elle va être de courte et un
ans ans ou dès que le confinement sera
arrêté et dès qu'on y verra plus clair
sur l'épidémie les choses vont reprendre
ce naturellement sur un sentier de
croissance qui était déjà pas bien
élevée avant le quoran égoïsme et va se
poursuivre avec des pics à la baisse
donc il ya ce confinement
deuxièmement c'est vrai qu'on a des
résultats négatifs sur l'emploi aux
états unis mais bon tout cela est
corrélé troisièmement il ya aussi
effectivement l'incertitude qui plane
autour du cac 40 avait des impacts sur
le cac 40
et aussi à des incertitudes politiques
sur les prises de décision en france
notamment
mais justement comment est-ce qu'on peut
anticiper l'ampleur de cette crise et
réduire les conséquences à ce qu'il peut
y avoir
après la crise une hausse de la
croissance
oui très clairement il y aura une
reprise spontanée spontanée de la
croissance presque en gérant de façon
très très vertical puisqu'il ya une
reprise de l'activité 17 de la fin des
confinement et j'espère avoir raison et
puis ensuite on va se retrouver à des
sentiers d'un pour cent à % et demi
deuxièmement une refonte de la politique
budgétaire puisque cette ce sera à
l'ordre du jour de toutes façons ensuite
les quelques résultats positifs quand
même sur la politique économique
française les 300 milliards de garanties
qui a prédit prolongement des systèmes
de survie en fait un lien sont finement
pour les entreprises comme le chômage
partiel
là les entreprises ont retrouvé leur
trésorerie pour payer normalement les
salaires et puis de façon globale tout
ce qui est sûr tout ce dont on parle ce
la refonde d'un modèle européen vers
plus de croissance et c'est enfin vous
connaissez des sujets maintenant mais
c'est sûr que ça va ça va repartir le
principal problème que les gens à mon
avis perçoivent à ses maths c'est qu'on
est sur une situation imposée d'un raid
activité vo c'est pas une question de
crise de régulation qu'ils voulaient et
donc il peut y avoir une bonne nouvelle
après quand la crise est finie avec une
croissance qui repart à la hausse mais
là concrètement en ce moment les
conséquences j'ai envie dire de
mauvaises augures ça va être quoi le
chômage de masse surendettement des
états est ce que c'est la fin aussi de
la mondialisation ou ou un changement de
doctrine peut-être vis-à-vis du
capitalisme à outrance est ce qu'on peut
avoir une prise de conscience je suis
complètement d'accord avec les
différents points donc le premier à m'en
bats un chômage en tout cas partiel
c'est déjà le cas un chômage de masse le
chômage va certainement augmenter
malheureusement parce que je sais
maintenant voilà c'est plus un scoop les
pme tpe commerçants artisans sont
extrêmement touchées les pme c'est 80
cent des emplois en france 90% même
d'ailleurs donc voilà il ya
indiscutablement maintenant ça peut
repartir aussi très très vite du côté de
l'emploi une fois que
le confinement encore une fois j'insiste
à peu est terminée deuxièmement des
bonnes nouvelles côté politique
budgétaire ce que les politiques
budgétaires vont être plus ciblés sur
les secteurs réellement touchés on va
enfin et faire du quantitatif
volumétrique mais plus du qualitatif
d'une certaine façon
et puis à la refonte aussi de la
politique monétaire qui a été
relativement inefficace à voir la bce
injecté 700 plus de 700 milliards 750
milliards mais on attend encore des
résultats à très court terme et
résultats peuvent être que en un second
tour qui concerne les politiques
monétaires ici dans ce cadre là donc il
faut attendre que le confit de francs
soit soit soit arrêté si vous voulez
après mondialisation c'est sûr qu'il ya
des vrais sujets de re localisation des
sites de production c'est sûr qu'on peut
pas renier et façon ferme et définitive
le fait que notre extrême dépendance des
vis de la chine a eu quand même des
conséquences importantes
c'est plus possible aujourd'hui donc de
toute façon je n'ai pas dit qu'on
reviendrait aux circuits courts
mais il y aura certainement des
réflexions un peu haut niveau merci
pascal de lima d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste